[Applause]
so
data and analytics are dramatically
changing our everyday lives
not just online not just in some distant
future
but in the physical world and in very
real and tangible ways
i spent the past 11 years of my life as
a geek
at mit working in big data labs that
seek to use data science
to study the physical world and try to
solve society's great problems
the field of big data seeks to analyze
massive pools of data
using computational tools to find
patterns
and trends data can be a really
extraordinary storyteller
unveiling the hidden narratives of
things in our everyday lives that we
never would have seen
i find the personal stories of inanimate
things brought to life
to be extraordinarily compelling i want
to highlight first
two projects from my time at mit that i
think highlight this phenomenon really
well
the first is called trash track and in
this project we sought to better
understand the waste management system
to answer the question where's your
trash go when you throw it away
your old coffee cup or that flip phone
that you carried around in the early
2000s
or a bagel or this morning's paper
where did these things go this data
didn't exist
so we had to create it we answered and
then visualized this question
by installing small sensors into pieces
of trash
and then throwing them into the waste
system and what you're seeing here
is the data every line every
node that you see is a single piece of
trash moving through the city of seattle
and then across the state and then
across the country
as weeks and months go by and it's
important to visualize this data because
none of you are probably sitting here
thinking yeah that looks right
that that's working like it should
right because no
what the data shows us is a highly
inefficient system
whose inherent brokenness i don't think
we really we really would have seen
had the censors not done the journalism
for us
a second project that i'd have to
highlight has to do with creating robots
that dive into sewers and sample waste
water
i know that sewage kind of gets a bad
rap but it's actually kind of
awesome because it can tell us an
incredible amount about the health of
our communities
this technology was spun out by a group
called biobot analytics
who's creating a cutting-edge technology
to turn our sewers
into modern day health observatories
their goal
is to study opioids within the sewage to
better understand consumption
in cities and this data is key because
it really helps cities understand where
people are using
how to allocate resource and the
effectiveness of programming
over time once again the technology
that's built into this machine
is pulling back the curtain and showing
us something about our cities that we
never would have seen without it
so it turns out as we see that big data
is really everywhere even in your toilet
and so now that we've talked about trash
and sewage
let's move on to food
a year ago i left mit to pursue a
passion in food
and in 2017 started a company with my
husband called family dinner
the goal of our company is to create
community around local food
and the people who grow it to make this
happen we're using data analytics
automation and technology to build a
distributed network of local farms
and to make improvements on the food
system so what we see here
is that the broad techniques and the
mission of what we're trying to do
is really not dissimilar from the work
at the mit labs
which brings us to a critical question
why
exactly would someone leave a very
promising career
at one of the top urban science labs in
the world
to drive carrots around in her mom's
acura
it's a great car because i believe
that the story of local food needs to be
understood
told and elevated and in many ways i
think that nerds like us
are really uniquely poised to tell it so
where are we starting what's our
starting point
the current national food system is
optimized for one thing only
and that's corporate profit right and
think about that
the most compelling reason for food
companies to exist
is not to feed hungry people it's not to
make delicious tasting food
it's profit and that has detrimental
effects at all levels of our food system
the antibiotics and pesticides that are
being put into our food are detrimental
to our health
price pressure is forcing small farms
out of business
in fact a lot of the things that you
think about farms no longer exist
farms don't look like farms they look
like factories
and at the end of the day the quality of
the food that we're eating really
suffers too
a factory farm tomato may kind of look
like a regular tomato bright red
exterior
but when you bite into it the taste and
texture just leave you wanting
and we know that perhaps the greatest
tragedy in all of this
is that between 30 and 40 of this food
is just
wasted thrown away that is 1.6 billion
tons i can't even wrap my head around
that number 1.6 billion tons
that's 1.2 trillion dollars a year
in wasted food that is the cost of
on-demand eating
and convenience and the broken food
system
now where's this waste happening where's
all this waste coming from
will we know that it happens in the
field when you don't pick the sexiest
looking potatoes
we know that it happens in transit at
the warehouses
in the grocery stores and finally on our
own kitchen counters
when we determined that that spotty
brown banana
no longer looks so yummy all that waste
all that effort food is planted
grown harvested shipped and then
just thrown away we think that there has
to be a better way
and so how do we improve upon this how
do we make a better system
in order to do this we understand that
we need to eliminate
waste in the food supply chain we need
to get data
in the hands of farmers so that they can
make better predictions
so they can you know kind of compete
with the big guy
and then finally we need to prize as a
company
quality and taste above everything so
that people really value the delicious
food on their plates
this we believe is the better system
this is the better way
and the path to that better way is paved
with data
to highlight all of this i want to tell
the tale of two tomatoes
we'll talk about them one by one a
tomato in itself contains a beautiful
snapshot
of everything you might want to know
about the life cycle of that fruit
where it was grown what it was treated
with nutritional value
miles traveled to get to your plate co2
emissions along the way
all of that information all those little
chapters
in one small fruit it's very exciting
this is tomato number one this is the
guy that you'll find
in sub shops supermarkets and fast food
joints along the world
it's got a really long and complicated
backstory
it's been treated with like a cocktail
of like a dozen
uh pesticides and it just traveled at
least 1600 miles
to get to your house and the image here
is green
because these tomatoes are picked when
green and hard as a rock
and then they are gassed along the way
so that when they arrive at the
destination
they look bright and shiny and red and
ripe
all of that effort all of that
agricultural innovation and technology
to create a product that is entirely
without taste
and onto the second tomato in our tale
this is the local version of the fruit
its story is much much shorter this guy
was grown by luke mahoney
and his family at brookford farm in
canterbury new hampshire
it's got a pretty boring backstory it
was planted
it sat in the sun and then it was picked
that's that's it like you wouldn't want
that yeah there's
not much more to that and it traveled
you know maybe 70 miles to get to your
plate
but the difference is dramatic i want
you to think about the last time you ate
a fresh summer tomato
and i know we're all covered in our
jackets but think about it the last time
you ate a tomato from the garden
it's warm from the sun richly red maybe
it smells like dirt
there's something nostalgic and almost
magical in that experience
the taste and the flavor are
incomparable
and we really don't have to travel super
far to get it
now this story extends up the food chain
from the fruits and the vegetables that
are on our plate
to the animals and the animal products
that we consume
what goes into raising them and more
importantly
what doesn't go into raising them is
critically important
luke and his family have 60 cows they
use traditional methods
they do it the old way pasture raised
no hormones no antibiotics hey for days
and what they're doing here is just
treating cows like they're
cows not like they're in a science
experiment
he's raising animals the way that his
grandfather and his
grandfather would have and at the end
it's just better
it's better for the animals it's better
for the environment luke is not
optimizing for profit or price
but for taste and for humanity
and what you're thinking is there's
already a solution to this
it's the farmers markets the ones that
many of you visit and the ones that i
really enjoy
they are a wonderful but in many ways
sub-optimal solution
for us as the consumers it's kind of
great right you go
there's this beautiful bounty of food
you get the warm and fuzzies for
supporting a local farm
and you get the experience of trying
something new and trying diverse
products
and inevitably there's some guy playing
a ukulele somewhere in the background
but for the farmers this presents a lot
of risk
right you wake up at four you pack your
truck you hire a team
you get to your stall but you have no
guarantees
that you're gonna move your product that
day there's too many variables in new
england
for example the weather which is just
like a little bit unpredictable here
the weather is one of many x factors
that determine whether or not a market
will be worth it
for the farmers every time they roll the
dice
and there's another option here we're
talking about csas
community supported agriculture in this
model
customers pay up front bearing the
financial risk for the farms
farmers grow what they can and the
customers enjoy that bounty
this also has a couple issues it's great
for the farmer
because they're ensuring that they'll
sell what they buy but for
us we still have to go and pick up that
share and we know that a lot of farms
can't grow a huge diversity of products
so sometimes you're stuck with a
mountain of any one particular thing
maybe this has happened to some of you
and what do you do
with 25 pounds of rutabaga in the dead
of winter i still don't know
so back to the question how do we fix
this
what we're hoping to do and we're hoping
to build is just a better way
to csa and there are three core
innovations that make this thing hum the
first of which is a subscription-based
e-commerce platform which helps us
create a consistent demand for our
farmers
throughout the year the subscription
part here is key
orders process weekly customers opt out
instead of often that means we've got
kind of the same number of orders
week to week second this means that
if farmers can sell online they're no
longer limited to the geography directly
around their farm
or to the number of markets that they
can sell we've blown the doors off of
that for them
second demand forecasting we're using
analytics to allow ourselves to look
into the future and forecast demand
this lets farmers know how much to
harvest in the near term
but also what to plant going forward if
a
200 order is processed on monday then we
buy to meet that exact demand
200 heads of broccoli 200 pieces of
salmon etc
etc this automation and ordering means
that here
we are eliminating the waste in the food
system that bothers us all so much
because we are ensuring that the supply
meets the exact
demand it also allows us to look into
the future with the farmers and do crop
planting
so if we can say to them in june of this
year i'm going to need
400 pounds of asparagus and 500 pounds
of berries every week
they can plant that accordingly knowing
with confidence that they will sell
everything that they have grown
and finally we use a route optimization
software
to help us solve the problem of the
traveling salesman we get a fleet of
workers to come in
and help us go the last mile bringing
all these goodies directly to your door
without data science and a super capable
wonderful team this none of this would
be possible
so maybe you've seen that we've got some
sort of fiery passionate core beliefs
yes we're trying to build a sustainable
business but our eye is not only on
profit
it's on building a better holistic
system of food
and here's what we value people first
we're trying to build community around
food the people who love it and the
people who grow it
we built this company to support small
farms
zero waste we all hate wasting food it
just feels wrong
even that weirdo banana that's been
sitting around on your coffee table for
too long
and lastly taste if it doesn't taste
good
if it's not that like perfect summer
tomato
why bother so what we've done is worked
with all these local farms to bring
their things in
and then to drop them directly at your
door so that we're connecting you right
to them
and making again a more holistic system
this is our vision of the future to
extend this model beyond boston
beyond new england and across the
country
to create a nationwide distributed
network of local farms
and to connect all these farmers with
the people like you
who love their food we believe
at the end of the day that really
insisting on eating local food
is a revolutionary act and we invite you
to join us
and who knows you may even make some
friends
along the way thank you very much